buonasera buonasera a tutti grazie a chi
ancora resiste nonostante loro siete
tantissimi a me è stato chiesto di
raccontare la mia storia e penso che non
ci sia niente di più bello che poterla
poterla raccontare e condividere per
raccontarlo deciso di partire da un po
lontano deciso di partire da da questo
verbo sconosciuto questo verbo è vero
per chi di voi hanno avuto la fortuna di
fare liceo classico perché io da lì ho
iniziato non sapevo esattamente che cosa
fare e la mia famiglia aveva raccontato
di quanto bello fosse il liceo classico
e ancora dovevo capire le mie passioni
beh da lì ho iniziato e questo verbo mi
è rimasto nei rimasto nel cuore mi è
rimasta nel cuore perché un verbo che
non si può dimenticare perché un verbo
di quelli che ti insegnano si deve stare
in testa a una declinazione impossibile
la sua declinazione fair offerse pooley
la tum
e poi torna a essere ferre ma perché è
un verbo però che è bellissimo perché
esprime in sé tutte le potenzialità che
hanno oggi i giovani per questo verbo
vuol dire fare nell'accezione che tutti
noi oggi utilizziamo be io ho iniziato a
fare quando quando ero al liceo ho
iniziato da li volevo fare qualcosa
volevo volevo crescere volevo avevo fame
fame di crescere cosa potevo fare mentre
era liceo beknown tante cose non potevo
cercare uno stage non c'erano i
contratti di apprendistato
forse all'epoca non c'erano neanche
google pro transito di fa ho pensato di
fare una cosa che mi avrebbe
incominciato a portare qualche soldino
ho iniziato a fare il cameriere un
mestiere umile un mestiere che mi ha
insegnato e mi ha regalato probabilmente
il primo abito e quando stato in ufficio
un abito nero con una camicia bianca e
ho incominciato a conoscere le persone
ho scoperto una cosa ho scoperto di
essere bravo a fare una cosa soltanto
che era quella di convincere le persone
a spendere di più quando venivano al
ristorante e l'ho letto ma perché non
farne una professione quale può essere
la professione nella quale anche se non
stai vendendo niente riesce a convincere
qualcuno della bontà dei tuoi prodotti
detto il mondo della pubblicità quale
cosa migliore che non convincere non una
ma tantissime persone
della bontà del tuo prodotto già ma come
fare
come potevo entrare nel mondo della
pubblicità mi sono guardato intorno ho
guardato le varie università e ho scelto
di fare mi dispiace non lo ied ma ho
scelto di fare la iulm non perché
credessi in quali strane o mirabolanti
competenze mi sarebbero arrivate dallo
studio di relazioni pubbliche e
pubblicità ma perché c'era una cosa a
lui ea lui un c'erano le persone che
facevano c'erano persone che lavoravano
nelle agenzie io li volevo andare beh in
università ha incominciato a fare una
cosa per la quale all'epoca non esisteva
neanche un verbo quella cosa che facevo
si chiamava stalking ovvero io aspettavo
i miei docenti quando scendevano da un
palco simile a questo e cominciava a
portare loro cose idee qualcosa che
faceva che produceva non senza
frustrazioni qualcuno stava dialogando
con qualcuno prima su twitter che mi
diceva ma le opportunità si cercano si
trovano si costruiscono ci vuole anche
fortuna nella vita
io l'ho cercata tante e tante volte
perché uno dei miei docenti ha preso è
letteralmente cestinato buttandolo giù
dal palco almeno 15 tesine prima che
viene portarsi una che l'ha
immediatamente affascinato da lì la mia
vita è cambiata ho iniziato uno stage
ho iniziato un ostaggio in agenzia
volevo fare il player volevo sera
qualcuno ha promesso reso conto che non
era esattamente la cosa che più mi
piaceva allora sono andato sotto nel mio
capi da letto sente mio stare dietro
alle scartoffie sta dietro i numeri le
presentazioni in power point
non ce la faccio voglio voglio andare
sul campo voglia di fare e fare qualcosa
ho letto bene se proprio vuoi cimentarti
aver bisogno di qualcuno che segue i
clienti che faccia la cava e da lì è
iniziato stato piccoli clienti
ho avuto avevo la fortuna di avere
questa voce anche a 21 anni quando
iniziata all'agenzia per cui mi
nascondevo dietro il telefono evitando
di andare alle presentazioni così che i
clienti avessero l'impressione di parola
sola persona molto più grande e da lì
sono cresciuto ho avuto la fortuna come
tante delle persone che erano qua sul
palco di trovare un mentore davanti ma è
una persona che davanti alle mie
richieste di fare di più mi ha dato la
possibilità di fare mi ha dato la
possibilità di sperimentare
e di rischiare anche con quel minimo di
pazzia che è propria di quando hai poco
più di vent'anni e che quella che fa sì
che tu possa avere il successo che vuoi
e quella fame con la pazzia che ti guida
e che ti costringe e ti porta a fare
delle richieste anche assurde che ti
costringono poi ammettere tutto se
stesso nel cercare di farlo per cinque
hanno gestito i più disparati clienti
sotto un periodo bellissimo poi un certo
punto mi sono stancato e ho chiesto di
fare qualche cosa d'altro beh nel 2008
sotto prese caricato su un aereo sullo
stato mandato in america per conoscere
le persone che avevano fondato negli
stati uniti l'agenzia che poi ho aperto
in italia
e lì ho iniziato una nuova carriera un
nuovo percorso
l'agenzia è nata come oggi con un
termine che oggi ma di no ad è stata una
startup c'era se persone oggi ce ne sono
con orgoglio posso dire che il 100 per
cento i loro oggi ha un contratto
regolare o una forma di apprendistato
dopo gli ultimi anni di fatica e in
questi cinque anni ho cresciuto ho
cresciuto questa agenzia che lavora per
per molti per molti clienti sono passati
dieci anni su un passato in realtà 15
anni da quando io ho conosciuto per la
prima volta il mio amico il verbo ferro
e oggi dopo dieci anni è giusto anche
tirare tirare un po i conti guardarsi in
faccia e cercare di capire che cosa è
successo
messi e guardo indietro vedo che è
cambiato tantissimo
vedo che il lavoro più faccio oggi non è
non solo quello che facevo
dieci anni fa è ovvio ma neanche quello
che facevo cinque anni fa ma neanche
quello che facevo tre mesi fa vedo un
mondo che cambia e che cambia con una
velocità esponenziale e questa velocità
con cui il mondo cambia e continua ad
evolversi a cambiare mi spaventa perché
la domanda che mi pongo oggi è che il
lavoro farò fra due anni e credo che sia
finito il tempo di quelle certezze che
una volta guidavano la vita del tenore o
che hanno guidato anche la vita di mio
padre di mia madre
il mondo oggi chiede qualcos'altro
questo qualcos'altro che chiede mi
spaventa mi spaventa ma credo che questa
paura se a quella che
nove le opportunità e l'opportunità che
i giovani oggi hanno squali o sprona
ogni giovane è quella di cogliere
l'opportunità di questo cambiamento di
questa paura perché soltanto i giovani
sono in grado secondo me di rispondere a
due domande che muto da una persona che
ho avuto modo di conoscere la settimana
scorsa che si chiama peter diamandis e
sono due domande talmente semplici che è
quasi impossibile rispondere
la prima domanda è ma se domani mattina
uno di voi si svegliasse con un miliardo
di euro che lavoro vorrebbe fare che
cosa vorrebbe costruire la seconda
domanda è
vi ricordate quando eravate piccoli
veicolati può andare avanti bambini
cos'è che vi dava felicità che cos'è che
era la vostra passione
cos'è che guidava le vostre giornate
tutti i giorni ecco io ci penso da due
giorni e ancora oggi non riesco a
trovare questa risposta però credo che
questa risposta non verrà da me credo
che verrà dai giovani perché soltanto i
giovani con questa voglia di cambiamento
prendo prendere questo verbo e
interpretarlo nel suo più grande
significato che non è quello di fare ma
è quello di guidare un cambiamento e
questo che invito tutti voi a fare
perché voi la possibilità di farlo ce
l'avete aiutare persone che anche come
me hanno fatto per ora la sua carta la
loro carriera ma oggi si aspettano da
quelle persone che hanno oggi vent'anni
la possibilità di portare il cambiamento
grazie